If I do all of this, uh, my hope is that
at the end of the three months, uh, I
will have made a significant improvement.
Steve Kaufmann here.
How do we maintain our commitment
in learning a language?
That's what I'm going to talk about today.
And I'm going to talk about it in the
context of my next 90-Day Challenge.
Now, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Now, you know, I often make the point
that language learning is not a sprint.
It's a long distance race.
It's not even a race, it's a journey.
And there was once, uh, I think
a movie called The Loneliness
of the Long Distance Runner.
And so as we're engaged in this long
distance process of learning a language,
it's easy to see our enthusiasm flag.
And that's why from time to time,
I join a challenge at LingQ.
And so I'm going to do a 90-Day
Challenge, but I'm going to
do three different challenges.
Now there's a place on LingQ where
it invites you to join a challenge.
So I joined the, um, Streak with
Steve challenge, which is where I'm
committed to maintaining my streak,
that I have to save so many LingQs,
create so many LingQs every day.
Um, so that's one.
But I'm also going to do a 90-Day
Challenge in Arabic and Persian.
So it's three challenges, but
it's really the same challenge.
What I'm committing to do is to save, to
create a minimum - and I'll go into how I
set these, my goals - but 13 LingQs a day
in Arabic and 13 LngQs a day in Persian.
Now the streaks that we track at
LingQ have to do with creating LingQs.
But that's not my only activity.
I'm going to be speaking with my tutors
two or three at least times a week.
One tutor in Arabic, one tutor in Persian.
I'm going to be doing my
usual reading and listening.
However, in order to meet my LingQs
target or goal I did a number of things.
First of all, I adjusted my daily
goal down because I, you know, if
you go to the settings gear symbol on
LingQ, you can set your daily goal.
And there's this sort of, you know,
intensive level, which I have done in the
past, which is a hundred LingQs a day.
And then there's what we call casual,
which is only 13 LingQs a day.
And so I adjusted my goals down to 13
because I want to maintain my streak.
I want to be able to do at least every
day, I want to do 13 saved LingQs in
at least one of the two languages.
So that means that I have
to bring in new material.
I have been in both Arabic and Persian,
I have been spending a lot of time
with my existing content because I
have so many saved LingQs, especially
in Arabic, words that, you know,
I've, I've looked up, they're now
yellow, but I still don't know them.
So I go back into content that
I've listened to before hoping
to move some of these to known.
The problem with that is the brain
doesn't remember much it seems.
It doesn't remember the
words, but it knows that the
content is not new any longer.
It's heard it before.
It's read it before.
So it's less stimulating for the brain.
So I'm going to force myself
to bring in new content.
Now this could be in the case of
Persian, some of the content that Sahra
is creating for me in Iran about...
she travels in her country
and this kind of thing.
Or
how about, uh, you know, she's done some
on, on a movie director in Iran, and
then she sends me a link to the movie.
So I'm going to try to see if I can
find these Iranian movies somewhere.
It's not that easy to do.
And of course the dialogue is very
fast and I don't understand it.
And we're trying to figure out
how I can maybe extract the
audio and we're working on that.
And of course, and with Arabic, uh, what
I want to do is I want to focus more on
to Arabic so that I can enjoy movies.
Cause right now I don't
understand the movies and most
of the movies come from Egypt.
And for that reason, I've started
talking to Mohammed, who is from Cairo.
And we started a few lessons
now in Egyptian Arabic.
I have listened to the mini stories
quite a few times in Egyptian Arabic.
And so then I get on with Mohammed
and I read a story and then he, and
because the stories consist of, you
know, part A, which is third person
and part b, which is first person
or past tense or future tense.
And then there are questions where
the answers are sort of provided.
And so he reads the statement, he
asks me a question and I'm reading
along and I answer reading along and
he corrects my pronunciation and this
gets me closer to Egyptian Arabic.
And I'm hoping that through
this process, I'll be able to
understand Egyptian movies.
So if I can continue my sort of input
activities, reading and listening if
I can get on with my tutors, do some
reading and some speaking, if I can access
now movies, which is the live language,
people living the language, over a period
of three months and, but every day I
have to find at least 13 new words that
I save as LingQs and put them into my
vast collection of, of saved LingQs that
I'm still trying to learn yellow words.
If I do all of this, uh, my hope is, uh,
that at the end of the three months, uh, I
will have made a significant improvement.
Uh, yeah, the idea of the, of
the challenge is, is, is not
that you're going to necessarily
measure how much better you became.
It is a little nudge to get
you going every day, because
I want to maintain my streak.
I want to save those 13 LingQs.
Uh, it's a bit of a commitment and I'm
hoping that other people on LingQ will
do the same and so we can compare.
It doesn't mean that everyone
is studying Arabic and Persian.
People might be studying
Chinese or Russian or Spanish or
Portuguese or whatever it is...
english.
Uh, but at least we're kind...
of that loneliness of
the long distance runner.
The loneliness of the
language learner is lessened.
To the extent that we can share our
experience, share our activities
and make sure that we maintain
our streaks or, you know, uh,
whatever level we set for ourselves,
goals that we set for ourselves.
So we're kind of collectively pushing
each other to work a little harder and
hopefully enjoy it more because the
goal ultimately is to enjoy learning
the language, not necessarily to,
I dunno, achieve some numerical number,
it's to feel more comfortable, more
engaged with learning the language.
At any rate, that is what I'm going
to do for the next three months.
It's a 90-Day Challenge.
I'm going to try to maintain my streak
and I'm going to try to see how far I
can push my, my numbers on my profile
at LingQ, known words and so forth.
But the only goal I'm going to
really track is to save LingQs.
That makes it easier for me, eh,
fewer, uh, you know, less pressure.
Um, I'm going to have these
increased, have this increased
interaction with my tutors.
I'm hoping that that will move me into
a situation where I can enjoy movies.
Then I have to persuade my
wife that we're going to watch
arabic or person movies rather
than whatever latest thing she's
found on Netflix or Amazon.
Right now we're enjoying a Danish
movie "By the Seaside" or something
of that nature from Amazon.
It's spectacular.
I love listening to Danish.
I don't understand it
as well as I would like.
Uh, I even ran through our
mini stories in Danish.
I see we only have 25.
I would love to have the full set of 60.
If there's any Danish people out there
that want to help us with getting more
content into LingQ, please let me know.
And I encourage all of you to make a
commitment to the next 90-Day Challenge.
Sign up at LingQ.
Thank you for listening.